the maid of leicester sir peter souls be
packed sure for everyone today so Peter
thanks for being with us and I wonder if
we can just get straight to the meat of
the discussion how comfortable are you
with Leicester entering lockdown on the
basis of the information provided to you
by central government and indeed being
provided to you by a local hospital
trusts well I think we're the first city
for this to happen but I suspect we
won't be the last
it's clear from figures in other cities
that there are going to be issues there
as well certainly being the first is not
a comfortable position to be in but it
is one that now the government has
announced some very wide-ranging
measures for our city that we're
determined to make sure they work make
sure we get through this as quickly as
we can and get out the other end the
reason I asked so Peter is yesterday
indeed at the weekend it did appear that
you were suggesting that the rationale
the data set had been provided for
bringing Leicester into lockdown once
again wasn't sufficient if you changed
your mind on that it's been incredibly
difficult getting data out of the
government it's now what 11 days since
the Secretary of State first announced
that he believed that there was an
outbreak here in Leicester and we've
spent a lot of time over the 11 days
trying to get the data trying to
understand what it is they believe is
happening in our city and also trying to
get them to commit to do the testing
here in Leicester because although they
did send a testing unit in here it
announced when it arrived that it was
only staying for the day and then was
going somewhere else and you know that
level of commitment is something that's
in a struggle for us and I'm glad now at
last we've got a clear way forward and a
clear commitment to support the city
have you been given any indication of
how this might be enforced particularly
you know as we head to a weekend on
which many people will be heading to
pubs to restaurants and so on to stop
people from the affected area taking
anything but essential journeys it's
obviously gonna be quite a challenge
enforcing it and clearly yeah you know
we're talking with the two Constable
yesterday about the role that he and his
officers will have to play in this
because obviously the council doesn't
resources do it I want instructor Peter
can you be specific what is this what is
this specific role that the police will
play in enforcing lists are we gonna see
roadblocks on the Donald min war zone no
I don't mean kilig that is wholly
impractical what we have been doing is
working with the County Council to
actually identify for the government
what is an appropriate boundary for this
lockdown because obviously the City
Council's administrative boundary is
very tightly drawn well within the whole
built-up area that people know of as
Lester and as yet the government hasn't
actually announced what it accepts to be
the the boundary this lockdown
so actually policing it is well gonna be
something of a challenge until we know
actually what the area is to be policed
so I can I just said you get you to
repeat that you do not yet know what the
limits are of this lockdown area the
suggestion and some of the copy kicking
around this morning is that it's three
miles to the north of the city center
three miles to the south of the city
center yeah and but obviously that you
know is obviously a very imprecise
description of it it may be that that's
how they ultimately do describe it but
whether it's a blue line on a map or a
radius from the from the clock tower
right at the heart of the city I think
we all need to know and as yet we don't
look alike be Claudia Webb really feel
really fears for the future of of
business unless they're given that
everyone was dealing up once again to
try and get us back if not to normalcy
then to course or to it than we've been
for quite a long time
do you share those concerns I guess of
course I do and you know they've just
when the retailers the the restaurants
the bars were beginning to stock up to
get ready to to to reopen they finding
that actually they have to play at pace
at least two more weeks with the closed
notice on the door and one thing that
have been pressing on the government and
they have promised to to provide it is
that we do need to be able to ensure
that they have the financial support
during this extra period of lockdown
that means that at the end of it our
economy is is able to bounce back
so Peter Saul's be good to see this
morning thanks for being weightless